but question for you from a different
standpoint
in
hollywood okay
i met my wife in the industry of finance
we were both at transamerica we met
there right many people meet their
spouse you know in within the business
in the in the business do people talk to
say
hey
never date somebody like you know how
the thing is never you know
you know date somebody's this or never
do is there anything that's say never
date another actress or never date
somebody that's not in the business is
there anything like that or not at all
yeah i mean people have reputations for
being uh unstable you know and dangerous
to date sure i mean when uh me too was
first breaking out i had a lot of very
famous friends freaking out
thinking i don't know what's gonna who's
gonna come forward from the hundred
girls i was with who you know just
decides that they didn't like what i did
that night four years ago and i'm
screwed and they would have been you
know and they were sweating it
so i think the future of you know a
signed contract is not that uh uh you
know not that crazy um but videos that
people have reputations sure and uh you
know it's it's disgust but by and large
all actors are crazy so you know what
you're getting into you know that's true
they were just nutty people um myself
included you know it's just it's a weird
kind of uh profession to pursue it's
that it's it's an insane profession to
pursue it's impossible the rejection is
constant so you kind of be that kind of
person who embraces rejection uh there's
got to be a lot of ego involved a lot of
ego i mean because if you're especially
if you're on camera how do i look how do
i how am i perceived how does the world
perceive me how am i viewing the world
like there's gotta be a lot of that on
the other hand celebrities the celebrity
bubble the fame bubble and this goes
back to amber and johnny is the fame
bubble is so insane like look what it
did to to to i have a controversial
opinion about say bruce jenner for
example um i think a lot of his
motivations have to do with the fact
that his family became more famous than
he did right um it can drive people nuts
it is so isolating it's like it's it's
not dissimilar to uh
when you're in prison and they put you
down below what is that called uh
solitary solitary confinement i mean
you're kind of free to roam but you're
not you're never alone the press is
always on you the more famous you are
the worse it is
and so other actors are pretty much the
only people who can understand you
so you have this dating pool of crazy uh
but it's limited to only other famous
people otherwise there's there's a power
imbalance there that you know once you
become famous
unfortunately i don't have this problem
but once you become famous uh
you you begin to doubt anybody else's
motives for even wanting to talk to you
because people want to be around famous
people and for better or worse fame is
power today fame is a superpower
clout yeah well right cloud chasing
whatever so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]